this video was made possible by my
lovely supporters on patreon last week i
saw a scientific paper that immediately
put me on the defensive it made the
counter-intuitive claim that the globe
warming was causing winters to become
colder specifically it was claiming that
climate change was causing winters in
north america to become colder via a
mechanism that i understood very well or
so i thought backstory you may recall
that earlier this year texas was hit by
a wave of extremely cold weather or that
in 2019 chicago was hit by similar
conditions in fact it was so cold in
chicago it was colder than the surface
of mars cold enough that people were
advised to not talk outside in case it
damaged their lungs or if you're here in
the uk you may remember the beast from
the east of 2018 this huge snowstorm
that covered the entire country all of
these events were caused by the
stratospheric polar vortex an enormous
doughnut of air spinning over the north
pole tens of kilometers above the
surface in one of the middle layers of
the atmosphere called the stratosphere
normally it rotates at about 200
kilometers per hour but roughly once
every other year it basically shreds
itself apart in an event called a sudden
stratospheric warming where in the space
of a week the middle atmosphere heats up
by tens of degrees celsius in the two
months or so after one of these events
weather at the surface is changed and
specifically it's changed because the
jet stream which is this ribbon of fast
moving air is moved further south and it
meanders around a bit more what that
means is air that's normally trapped
over the arctic is allowed to meander a
bit further south and sit over the uk or
over chicago the physical mechanism by
which the vortex and the jet stream are
coupled isn't exactly known but what we
know for sure is that when the vortex
yields itself apart extremely cold
weather events are much more likely in
the vicinity of the jet stream i did my
phd on this phenomenon and i've done a
whole video on my thesis if you'd like a
bit more detail about that whilst i was
doing my research one of the big debates
was and really still is if these sudden
stratospheric warming events are
becoming more frequent with climate
change the argument goes that because
the arctic is warming much faster than
the rest of the world due to a
phenomenon called arctic amplification
the temperature gradient between the
pole and the equator is lessening and
because that gradient is what drives the
polar vortex the vortex is getting
weaker and a weaker vortex is more
easily disrupted which means more of
these southern stratospheric warming
events however the debate isn't settled
we're limited by the fact that these
events don't happen that frequently and
we don't have that long a time series to
look at they were only discovered in the
50s so much of the debate is based on
how different computer models represent
the polar vortex and
that can vary pretty wildly so when i
saw this paper seemingly weighing in
decisively on the these events are
getting more frequent with climate
change side i thought
here we go again but it turns out the
paper isn't talking about the aftermath
of these sub-stratospheric warming
events researchers have been so focused
on these incredibly violent events and
they are they're the most violent thing
in the whole atmosphere
that to date they basically missed
something that was right under their
noses because as it turns out the vortex
doesn't need to completely tear itself
apart in order to influence weather at
the surface in this paper researchers
used machine learning techniques to
troll through past atmospheric data and
identified a set of atmospheric
conditions that when they're met the
polar vortex doesn't break apart but
instead is stretched it's elongated over
north america and this vortex stretching
has the ultimate effect of modifying the
pressure gradient across the continental
us from east to west to use pressure
terminology it amplifies the
climatological ridge and trough and
because of how fluid flows on a rotating
sphere that increased pressure gradient
from east to west results in more arctic
air being transported from north to
south to the continental united states
so in the aftermath of one of these
vortex stretching events you see
widespread cold temperatures across the
us and the temperature difference is of
a comparable magnitude to those seen
after a sudden warming event like we saw
in chicago for example now i've got to
say i'm a dynamicist so i think this
stuff is really cool anyway but that's
not all that this paper did using
statistical analysis and a dynamical
analysis using a simplified model of the
earth's atmosphere the researchers
identified that because of arctic
amplification the arctic getting warmer
than elsewhere and specifically because
the arctic was losing its sea ice
the precursor conditions for these
vortex stretching events were being met
more frequently and so because of
climate change these vortex stretching
events were becoming more frequent and
further that the statistical link
between climate change and vortex
stretching was more robust than the link
between climate change and sudden
warming events so we're left in this
weird counter-intuitive position of the
world warming and the arctic warming in
particular
leading to winters in north america and
east asia on average getting
colder and this is something that is
born out in the data if you look at the
time series of snowfall and snow
coverage in the high latitudes in the
northern hemisphere so the region
surrounding the arctic
while sea ice extent has been shrinking
and the arctic's been getting warmer
the winters in the northern hemisphere
were getting colder and the snowfall has
increased over the same time period and
i find this fascinating for a couple of
reasons first it shows the pitfalls of
how specialist science has become i mean
i did a phd on pretty much this exact
phenomenon on these southern warming
events and we were so focused on that
that we missed the possibility that the
vortex could just get
distorted distended and i guess it shows
that you have to be creative and in this
case it was creative in terms of the
tools being used machine learning to
overcome the limitations of your narrow
specialism of your niche niche if you're
american second it shows that climate
change is not just the globe warming
it's more complicated than that
sometimes there are these
counter-intuitive effects like north
american winters getting colder it
neatly demonstrates that climate change
isn't warming climate change is extra
energy being added to weather systems
unevenly all over the planet and yes
that often results in warming but
sometimes the effects can be
counterintuitive and third it
demonstrates the paradigm shift that is
going on in atmospheric science we've
gone from one paradigm of a relatively
static climate to a rapidly changing
climate and that has necessitated
reevaluating everything we think we know
about the atmosphere from a dynamics
perspective climate change is very much
the greatest threat that humanity faces
right now but it's also a phenomenal
opportunity to better understand the
physical system of our atmosphere the
physical system that mediates grants us
our weather and literally the air that
we breathe this paper i think is a great
example of that but yeah if you live in
north america maybe look at investing in
a winterwear company
feels like it would probably be a good
investment feels like i'm wearing
nothing at all
this was quite a different video to the
kind of thing i normally make so let me
know what you thought down in the
comments would you want it to be shorter
or longer or more detail or less detail
basically i saw an interesting paper
geeked out and i just wanted to make a
video about it as i mentioned at the
start this video was only made possible
and my bills this week were only paid by
my lovely supporters on patreon if you'd
like to become a supporter of this
channel and support more videos like
this one then the links on screen right
now and in the description if you would
like to support me in a non-monetary way
then just watching this video and liking
it and sharing it with people that you
think might be interested is more than
enough support so if you're doing that
thank you very much if you'd like some
recommended viewing next then you can
check out some of my videos up here that
just leaves me to say thank you very
much for watching i hope you liked it if
you did please do pop it a like and
i'll see you in the next one